the Academy is making some big changes
to the Oscars telecast this year they're
not having a host what's going on with
the musical numbers what's gonna happen
I don't know let's talk about it Denney
directors joining me today and he's my
soul mate
oh my god first of all you know what I
am okay with this full glam look oh my
god
thank you okay so how do you feel about
all the changes that the Academy is
making this year - if it ain't broke
don't fix it telecast I'm like figuring
it out
you know just figure it out I mean I
feel like it's been a year of
shenanigans from the Academy and at this
point I'm like just hand out the
trophies let's get this over with right
yeah I mean well this is the first host
list Oscar since 1989 I want to say yeah
um so they had Kevin Hart as the host
and then he stepped back and then they
never replaced him how do you feel about
having a hostess Oscars I am okay
without having a host for the Oscars I
don't know if I feel that way for every
Oscars but for this year for sure I mean
in light of the Kevin Hart controversy
and hit him
piecing out I feel like hosting the
Oscars already is such a thankless job
and no matter who they replaced Kevin
Hart with that person would be not Kevin
Hart see I kind of wanted them at this
point just to do a contest get it
up-and-coming comedian and he'll do that
and have it be their platform to get
there like you it doesn't need to be the
rocker Kevin Hart or you know some
a-list celebrity just make it somebody
that's gonna deliver a good show and
also steer the ship that what I'm most
concerned about yeah what are they gonna
do if we have a la la land moment that
who steps out and intervenes they're
just like oh well we don't have a host
that's why you have to book the right
presenters it's gotta be funny people
actors who are on their ish you know
what I mean ain't like I think you have
to rely on the presenters in this case
uh I will say that is probably the only
con if something goes AWOL you know
something just like something goes
really really wrong they're gonna need
someone to kind of help bring it back
you know so that's why you got to hire
the right people to present see I love a
monologue though like I Jamie Kimmel is
like forever my favorite like I love
going out there picking fun of everybody
in the audience yeah I love that and the
fact that we're gonna be robbed of that
I'll be robbed of a musical number I
need an opening music enough I know that
doesn't happen ever
year they're not all Hugh Jackman but
give me that they can still do it though
they still do what music whatever I've
heard like rumors that they're doing it
but I haven't seen anything official did
it Rob Lowe do it
yeah that's an issue oh my god ash you
know what I'm okay with they should get
Rob Lowe to do to come back and do this
every team self bring snow white back no
no no bring Princess Elsa bring Queen
Elsa from frozen do an opening number
redeem yourself from 1989 okay I'm
usually just like the musical number
it's just like wolya when I get my food
and all that stuff and then I sit down
no well I'm agreed a showman so it's
like I need it you know what else I'm
worried about so there was talk of let's
talk about the musical numbers yes sir
nothing he's gonna versus musical
performance because the Academy was like
we're only gonna have two this year and
then they were like just kidding we're
gonna have more and now I'm worried
about are they gonna do like a medley in
the beginning are they gonna really take
time to give every single person their
time to shine look the Oscars are
already so stuffy and I feel like the
musical performances are those breaks in
between that levity right and plus they
have some heavy hitters nominated some
huge huge artists Lady Gaga Kendrick
Lamar Jennifer Hudson scenes outfight
you know so I'm hoping that they spread
them out don't put them all in one place
they did that one year it just doesn't
work yeah this is my moment to say
justice for Emily Blunt right like I
don't know if it's her or them but
everything in the universe is happening
to keep her off that stays the Academy
right first of all she was robbed of a
Best Actress nomination then the Academy
tweeted that her song for Mary Poppins
is nominated but that a surprise guest
will be performing it Julie Andrews of
course is like the obvious answer but
she doesn't sing anymore sing anymore
eg did talk to Emily at the London
premiere of Mary Poppins returns and
said hey there's a chance that like you
your song could be nominated and you
would perform the Oscars how do you feel
about that she's a she was like my
stomach's already turning so maybe with
her but I will say that like the Academy
is cracking down they're trying to get
it to just be a three-hour yes and that
I'm here for that that's why I'm like we
don't need a host like that'll kind of
help but I also don't want the
performances to be cut short so I'm kind
of
like in the middle with me yeah my first
thought was like everybody's getting
played off that stage because
traditionally in the past you know a
couple of decades they've been about
three and a half hours approaching on
four hours done but they also announced
that they weren't going to present every
single award during the telecast on
there was gonna be ones given during the
commercial breaks i from a viewer
perspective understand that some of
those below-the-line categories we don't
care we people don't be very care about
yeah to me like as somebody that loves
film and and those below the line people
are like some of the most important
people that brought the film to life and
I think they deserve their moment I will
say that's where I'm like okay that's
where I'm gonna renege a little bit on
the three-hour telecast I'm like I feel
bad that those technical categories
won't get the same moment that say like
a Meryl Streep has in the past or you
know Best Director Best Picture but I
feel like we don't know this yet but
maybe they can't cuz they are shooting
them in the commercial they're gonna
edit them down maybe and show us like on
the way into the next commercial or
something I feel like it's gonna be
coming back for a short break and be
like so and so just one for sound mixing
and I'm gonna be like and then those
other nominees don't get their moment to
it that does yeah their names aren't
even called I think I just feel like I
deserve them I would rather have a
three-and-a-half hour telecast to get
those categories because the Oscars was
probably we don't know which category is
what it looks like Best Actress sorry
Glenn Close you've been long overdue for
this Oscar but we're not gonna show it
we're showing sound mixing we don't know
what categories and I will say what has
been so special about the Oscars it's
like it's one of the few major showbiz
awards that does show all those other
technical categories I don't say smaller
because they're all equally important
but yeah because you know the Grammys
has a pre telecast Globes doesn't even
alright I'm like Oscar they at least
showed it so that will be different I
will say the positive though I do kind
of feel like they're listening to their
audience because they added that popular
film category everybody was so mad and
then they took it away and then they
added they said no there's gonna be two
musical performances and then people
like lin-manuel Miranda and you know
people were disappointed upset and they
took it they they took it back yeah they
brought it in all five not nice does
make me feel like they do listen to the
input I just feel like it's a little too
late though I mean yeah
these approve changes right the board
did in August that's not much time to
change things that like look at what's
happening yeah and then the musical
performance things happened what the
other day right right there just now
tweeting that these people are
performing it feels a little chaotic
going yes given that it's a few weeks
away that's my problem
Academy figure it out figure it out
figure it out I mean the popular film
category I don't know whose idea that
was but I'm so glad that's not happening
I felt to me like a consolation prize
but again that was like the beginning of
all of this others like happening with
the Oscars and that's why I'm like
exhausted from all the shin and
just give us like a stunt category I've
been saying this forever
we've all been saying it those are the
tweets you need to listen to it we just
want a stunt category the superheroes
honestly and I'm afraid that Black
Panther wouldn't have been in the Best
Picture a little list of Best Picture
nominees if there was the popular film
category I deserve to be so I'm glad
that like they got rid of that and black
panther is showing up but on the flip
side of that if they do get in the
popular film category they probably
would have want it which in the Best
Picture they may not win but again it
just felt like a consolation prize I
agree there's a lot going on yeah okay
so we could dive into this for like four
more hours overall thoughts are you okay
with the Academy changes this year I'm
okay with them going without a host I'm
okay with them really cracking down and
trying to do it three hours under three
hours I'm not okay with them cutting out
the other categories from natural
telecast I'm gonna say I'm not okay with
it maybe I just hate change and then the
telecast will surprise me I'll be like
that was great but like here's hoping I
love a host I want to see those uh those
categories honored and I want all the
musical performances sir and bring back
Rob Lowe I'm pitching this that's just
for Emily Blunt and Rob Lowe that idea
where can people tweet you and see you
oh I'm at D direct oh and also you guys
you can catch me on et live Monday
through Friday we are live 24/7 so make
sure you download the app or watch us at
ET live.com thank you for that shameless
plug he used to sit next to me and then
you move then it was really tragic for
me and we'll get into that in a future
episode
I love what you've done with the place
oh yeah - Carlson you can find me there
and until next time we're okay with it
no we're not there's no water in this
[Music]